run through these but I want to draw
your attention to something additional
which we haven't been in calculus hand
for a while so you may have forgotten
this okay when we first learned calculus
we had to develop a bunch of different
terms of notation and they're probably
all mixed together in your brain and
often like I've been looking at you're
working over the last days and they're a
bit mixed up okay
so gentlemen are you ready to go so I'm
looking for an answer to my question it
wasn't one of those one of those how are
you questions where I don't want the
answer I actually wanted answers are we
really good okay Todd you have a
question you're it okay right let's
let's start off part a what do you kick
us off tup okay so let's you had a few
questions in it cause the short answer
is yes it is before I actually write
down the answer cause etc um when you
get given a function and you just gets
hard to differentiate what you call the
derivative kind of depends on what the
original function also gets called now
this original function doesn't give it a
name like this or this is just there it
is so in your book what I'd love you if
you haven't already the way I'd want
after you to write this down is to say
here's the function you're being asked
to differentiate our notation for that
looks like so okay I know a lot of you
because I've seen it in your books and I
used to do this when I was your age
we'll just write D on DX equals because
you're like I haven't been called it's
not Y so I can't put a Y in there the
problem with that is this is what we
call an operator do you remember that
word from earlier this year it operates
on a theme like the square root like the
log like like sine and cos and tan
itself so there has to be something in
there Deonne DX has to operate on
something this is the something so now
coming back to Tyler suggestion it is
cos what is that stuff on the inside by
the way X plus PI on four okay
now it just so it turns out this is the
final answer but at least in the way
that I work this there's actually an
additional thing I would write down even
though this is the final answer is
correct what do you think might be
missing well were you reckon x one now I
made a point about this yesterday right
why do we need to why do I
think it's important to multiply by one
State against right good so when we use
chain rule right we didn't actually say
that at the beginning we used it because
there's a function tucked inside there X
plus planet fourth that's a function and
then we applied sign to that now in this
case I gave you a nice easy one to start
off with the derivative of that inside
one that's why doesn't change things but
I do like putting it down because as
exactly Sarang said because he's
well-trained it shows it communicates I
know Antonio okay okay who can tell us
what to write for Part B any suggestions
so you just gave us a great answer so
let's see someone else you can pick up
go ahead it on dy on DX I'm just going
to post before I write the rest of the
shots I saw you notice why he's called
it why because started off here wouldn't
call it AF - or something like that
right it's got a name use it okay and as
Deshawn said a half sick squared exit
sitting out the front if you're
differentiating 5x squared you would
think okay I'm gonna do this guy ignore
the five and then I'm gonna put the five
back it's the same deal with this half
at the front so tan differentiate into
SEC squared then the half comes back out
the front that's a great question so in
your calculator how do you deal with
these things and actually this is a
perfect example to pull on so I'm just
gonna wait for a second just so I have
everyone's attention cool thank you this
is tricky on a few levels firstly in
terms of that squared what do you do
with that well it is true this is
shorthand for the whole thing SEC X the
whole thing is being squared can anyone
tell me why don't we write just the
sweat on the end why why do we not do
that
yeah it's sort of ambiguous isn't it
like which thing is squaring is the
whole thing or is it just the inside
part right now this is our shorthand the
other thing is unfortunately the
calculator is worse than that it doesn't
have a sync button what does it have
yeah you're gonna have to do one over
just like this okay and then off you go
that's what you have to actually import
so far so good
all right last one pottsy before we even
get to the derivative what do we call
the derivative F - fantastic so you
actually have a choice
right I've written this as 1 over cos so
you can write the derivative or you can
get to the derivative in one of two ways
you've got two rules what's wrong did
you guys use okay so I could treat this
guy I could rewrite it as SEC right and
the problem is I actually don't know
like in my head I don't have a
derivative for sec X it's not on the
reference sheet so even though it's a
more concise way to write it it doesn't
help me differentiate it have a look
I've written as a fraction right so
what's the most obvious rule you could
use is it negative Cosette the short
answer is no it's really confusing
getting our reciprocal relationships
right I'm going to shelve the idea of
Kosek for now we'll come back to a later
exactly did you have a suggestion what
to do with it so the most obvious thing
to do at the outset is use the question
all hands up if you use the question
rule hands up okay and that's fine you
use the question or it'll work okay
there is an alternative and I'm just
going to put to all of you whichever
method I'm about to we're about to do I
want you to do the other one so you have
both there what's an alternative way to
consider the derivative of this one over
like you've got the quotient rule
you've only got two other rules that
help you deal with functions and when
you're differentiating what have you
ever - if you're not dividing if you're
multiplying where you call out product
rule right and then there's one more
we used it up here what's it called the
chain rule right now how can we write
this in terms of the chain rule have a
think when you've got something on the
bottom of a fraction you can write with
a power right - one where does the minus
one go
it's the index right so I could
alternatively have written f of X like
this cause X to the power of negative 1
okay did anyone do it this way okay
interesting all right so being that
being that no one did it this way let's
all do it this way together and then
we'll quickly compare it to the question
wrong okay I'm gonna do it via the chain
the chain rule requires me to do an
inside and then outside derivative
inside derivative outside derivatives so
let's good the inside cause X what is
the inside derivative in this case it'll
be negative sign very good that's sneaky
it's got a minus sign okay where to go
and then having done the inside let's go
back to doing that can we do the outside
it's something to the power of negative
1
how do we differentiate that okay so
hold on so this power is going to
decrease by 1 hence becoming -2 but then
there's another thing we have to do with
that power and I generally do it before
we change it to vomity yeah it comes out
the front right we multiply by that
power and I'm leaving this gap because
you multiply by the power before you
bring it down right so I'm gonna put in
that minus 1 here like so does that make
sense to you inside derivative in fact
I'm even gonna write it he's the inside
derivative ah good question let me just
write this first and I'll explain why
the answer is no when we do the chain
rule right and we did it up here let me
remind you with like a a polynomial
example if I ask you to do this guy 3x
minus 1 to the power 7 yeah yeah very
good so when you differentiate this that
3x minus 1 it's going to stay 3x minus 1
you will multiply by the power reduced
by 1 and so on
ok all right now this is correct but
it's a mess how can I simplify it
what specifically can I do we've got
some tracers there's at least two things
that are pretty easy to spice we'll go
ahead yeah fantastic so two negatives
they cancel out that's great so I'm
going to start by writing out sine X
without the negative have you been
cancelled now have a look over here
you've got cause X to the power of
negative two what does that negative
mean where do I write this thing I don't
generally write writing things with
negative powers I really if it was
helpful
it's a it's a fraction right I did it
because it was useful to me it should be
on the denominator right do you agree
with that that's squared on the
denominator there you go okay now with
that I'm happy with that but just as an
added bonus I could write this in an
even lazier way this sign over cause
tacked in there do you see that sign
over close what's our abbreviation if
it's sign over cuz it's ten right so I
could say that's ten then there's also
after I've done sign it because there's
a 1 over cause still left behind
what's our abbreviation for 1 over cause
SEC so this is our derivative
both of these are equivalent but this is
just slightly lazier our way to write it
because there's no fractions or anything
like that okay are you happy